-You look gorgeous.
Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you very much.
-I love having you here.
You know, we were both --
We attended the Met Gala...
-We did.
-...the same night.
I didn't get a chance to see
you, but I did see the pictures.
Look at this.
-Oh. Thank you.
-Look at this. Gorgeous.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stunning.
-Didn't see you.
I did see Seth Meyers.
-You saw Seth? Oh, yeah?
Who else did you hang --
Who sat at your table?
-I was on a table with
Kourtney Kardashian
and Travis Barker.
-Oh, they're fun!
-Yeah.
-I love them.
-It was -- Well, it was --
I needed to, like, have an in
to the conversation,
have something to say,
something interesting for them
to, you know, to know.
-Yeah.
But they did dress up as
Sid and Nancy for Halloween
two years ago, a year ago.
So, then my thought was,
"I'm in a show and Sid and Nancy
are in that show.
And I'm in it, too, and so hi."
-"I can relate to you!
We're the same people!"
-And they were like, "Great!
We can't wait to watch it."
And then, that was it.
We were best friends.
-They're fun, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I do want to talk about
"Pistol,"
The new Sex Pistols thing.
I do want to talk about it.
When you're at those Met Galas,
do you get star struck by
anyone, or not really?
-I do, but I really
try to play it cool.
I try to not overdo it.
You know?
Although sometimes
that doesn't go quite so well.
Because one time I was at a U2
concert and Bono was backstage,
and everyone was
gonna go and say hi to Bono.
And I didn't want to be like,
"Hi. I'm Maisie.
I know who you are."
[ Laughter ]
But then I just ended up
being like,
"Hi. I'm Maisie.
What's your name?"
[ Laughter ]
-To Bono?
-To Bono.
[ Laughter ]
-At a U2 concert.
-Yeah, and he was just like,
"What are you doing?"
I played it too cool.
-That's actually way too cool.
He probably liked that. Yeah,
he's like, "What's my name?"
[ Laughter ]
At a U2 concert.
"Well, I'm Bono.
Nice to meet you."
-Yeah, it was so weird.
-You were trending on Twitter
recently because they just
announced this new video game,
called "MultiVersus."
-Yes.
And Arya Stark is in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You are in the --
You love video games.
-I do love video games.
-What does this feel like?
You're in this game.
-I felt woefully underprepared,
actually.
'Cause when I went there,
I thought it was gonna be
kind of like a quest-style game,
and it was gonna be, like,
young warrior.
-RPG thing, yes.
-Yeah, yeah, you need to --
And then it was actually just
this battle game,
and I had to do all these lines
where I'm, like,
cussing out
other cartoon characters.
Like,
"What's up, Bugs Bunny?"
[ Laughter ]
And it was, like,
kind of wild, so...
-I want to talk about
your new show, series, "Pistol."
-Yes.
-This is the story of how
the Sex Pistols formed.
-It is.
Now, you play Jordan,
who is a punk icon,
very close with the band.
Here's a photo of you as Jordan
and the real Jordan split.
Look at that.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yeah, super cool.
-Oh!
-Well done.
It fits good.
It fits perfect.
-Yes.
-And the real Jordan passed
away, sadly, last month,
but you got to meet her
and talk with her.
-I did.
Yeah, Jordan was a consultant
on the show, and she sculpted
everything with my image,
but also kind of
a lot of different teams,
you know,
with everyone's costume,
everyone's hair and makeup,
and she was there.
-And how was she?
Just cool, right?
-Yeah, just incredible.
It's, you know, quite
intimidating to be around her.
But to be around someone who's
just so sure of themself and,
you know, just remembers
this time with such --
just such a good perspective,
it was just
a benefit to all of us.
And I feel really,
really grateful to have
gotten to spend
some time with her.
-Here's a picture of you
and the real Jordan.
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
Man, she had good style, huh?
-Yeah.
-The Sex Pistols --
If you love music,
you know the Sex Pistols.
I know a little bit
of the story,
but I always want to know more.
-Yes.
-Has it changed the way
you think of music now?
-Definitely.
I think the --
You know, we shot
this during COVID,
and we basically
got to go and watch live gigs
every day because the boys
who are playing the Pistols,
they learn all their
instruments, all of the songs,
and played live
every single day.
And for me, that's, like,
how the Pistols
are supposed to be experienced,
you know?
Like, that was the way
that they really shine.
And my experience sort of
listening to music
is, like, much more on radio,
or it's people's music videos,
or it's their image
on social media.
-Some songs are made for radio.
-Right, exactly.
And so I think it's kind of --
Like, I've been really intrigued
to figure out what artists
I need to watch live
and what artists, like, are
better on your headphones
or, like, whatever.
-Yeah.
-So, I think I appreciate
the live performance a lot more.
And I'm kind of, like,
seeking out those artists
'cause they're harder
to come by now.
-I'm excited about this one.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Maisie Williams
in "Pistol."
Take a look at this.
-You've got nothing.
You know nothing.
And if you stay here,
you'll become nothing.
-You think we're just stupid
little girls, but we're punks.
You're just old.
-Old? Well...
-We're the new generation gap.
-Good for you.
And how long before you're
the old "new" generation gap?
What will you have then
but to trade boring stories
about how you were once
the brightest young things
at some gig
no one even remembers?
Go home.
Learn things.
Get clever.
Make your own destiny.
-Yeah.
Get clever!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maisie Williams!
All six episodes of "Pistol"
begin streaming May 31st
on Hulu.